les températures sont aujourd'hui plus
clémente avec des nuits entre 4 et 9
degrés mais au matelot à versailles le
plan grand froid a permis d'accueillir
60 personnes venant des yvelines de
seine saint denis et 2 paris l'intérêt
c'est qu'il y en a quelques-uns qui ont
pu effectivement à la fin de cette année
en froid passé sur une place hivernale
puisque nous avons ouvert dix places
hivernales à la place des places grand
froid
la halte de versailles a aussi accueilli
dix hommes isolés supplémentaires la
préfecture ne note pas de pression
particulière dans les centres
d'hébergement les personnes ont été
mises à l'abri en amont depuis le mois
de novembre une circulaire dégâts que
nous mettions sallabi toute personne qui
ont finalement donc dans le calme cette
mise à la zone exceptionnelle on avait
les verts d'ores et déjà environ 450
places d'hébergement d'urgence
on a doublé le nombre des clips mobile
qui circulent sur le département des
yvelines à la rencontre des sans abri
il ya trois équipes mobiles qui
circulent normalement et on est passé à
6 et on a aussi augmenté nos habitudes
horaires pour leur permettre d'aller
vers les personnes je suis à 5 heures du
matin un millier de places dans des
hôtels ont aussi été créés les yvelines
compte près de 3000 places réparties
dans les centres d'hébergement d'urgence